on the same day that mac jones and
others were working out in tuscaloosa
for alabama pro day two it was ohio
state pro day one
in columbus justin fields had
a zack wilson type throw it had a lot of
people excited on social media
afterward justin fields explained
that throw here's the question and
justin fields answer
justin was that throw to cj on the
script before the world saw zach wilson
do something similar last week because i
know john
scripted the workout for both you guys
yeah so it's it's actually funny so me
and
of course zach were both working out in
california so we kind of you know
pretty much had a similar script in
terms of what throws we're hitting
probably just different movements
but um yeah um so that that throw was
was on there before i even left
california so
um you know i i thought i could show
that throw off and of course that's what
i
showed today hey impressive throw
reminded me of some of the throws he
made against clemson he was fantastic
yeah in the clemson game and you know
going into the 2020 college football
season and it was turned upside down far
more than the nfl season because of the
pandemic
it was trevor lawrence justin fields
those were the two guys regarded as the
top quarterbacks and i thought justin
fields really helped himself
beating trevor lawrence yeah right
college football
semifinal but let's not get it twisted
and i don't want to take anything away
from what justin fields did sprinting to
his left
and throwing that ball down the left
sideline but that's not the zack wilson
throw
the zack wilson throw is all of that
plus
flick of the wrist across the body chris
chris which is far more difficult
that no what field did was great right
what wilson did was spectacular because
it was across the body
right well yeah wilson does this right
he's throwing it the other direction
so there's a much higher degree of
difficulty with that throw
not a cr i've misspoke not across the
body but no but
running left and throw right exactly
throw it running left now
fading left and throwing left your
momentum's taking you there it's easier
to do that
running left fading left and now
throwing a post route across the field
opposite of the direction your body and
momentum are taking you
definitely is a bigger degree of
difficulty let alone mike we saw him do
it
to the opposite side of the field on a
39-yard
corner route too you know mike you heard
this analogy i said again justin feels
what he did was really
impressive and and i like i said
you know after the zack wilson workout
yeah there's lots of quarterbacks
that can do that but it doesn't mean
they can do it to the level
that he can do it that's where i want to
like you know every
there's a lot of guys that can dunk in
the nba there's a lot of them
but they can't dunk like jordan and
lebron there's just something about the
way they
jump the explosiveness you know how high
they get
you know their ability to hang in the
air that extra second
well there's a difference there too you
know it's like you said the flick of the
wrist
how quick the motion was from zack
wilson
and then the way the ball explodes out
of his hands
is what makes it special and i don't
want to take anything away from justin
fields either because he did some
awesome things in that workout yesterday
he's definitely going to make teams feel
more comfortable about him and what he
did in the process
he's fixed he you know he cleaned up
some of the mechanical issues
that you worry about you know not that
i'm saying they're gone forever but he
certainly you could see that he's worked
on him and thought about them a little
bit
and he's he's got high-end talent i mean
gosh
damn he ran 4-4 he's 230-something
pounds
and he has a rifle for an arm and those
are a lot of positive things for an nfl
team to like
we just played that big throw that was
compared to the wilson throw
and the one difference that cries out to
me and
and i i i i think justin fields is gonna
be a great nfl player yeah
he put a hell of a lot more air effort
and arm into that throw the wilson thing
was just
it was it it it's that quick flick of
the rest that we see from patrick
mahomes
that i think is one of the big reasons
why you've got wilson
ahead of all the other guys you've got
him at number two or
you've got number one over trevor
lawrence even though you accept the fact
that the jaguars are locked in on
lawrence you've got them all the way at
number one
because of that quality where you can
get rid of the ball so quickly
so easily any body position any arm
angle
flick it like patrick mahomes it's a
rare talent and we got another guy
coming to the nfl
who can do that on a regular basis yeah
exactly you know and again
justin fields definitely has some elite
traits and could be a
big time nfl starting quarterback
there's things to be excited about in
his game
yeah but i'm not as excited about it as
i am
zach wilson no you know again i what
i'll take away from that too
where i thought oh maybe justin field's
arm is stronger if they just throw it as
hard as they can right compared to zack
wilson but zach wilson can paint corners
and throw the ball really hard in all
the awkward positions but no i come away
from that workout yesterday going
no justin field's arm is not stronger
than zach wilson's in any setting in any
form and any throw
you know but yes wilson's workout
was special the quickness in the which
that he throws the ball
the way he spins the ball the way the
ball explodes out of his hands
is different it it and it's not to say
that
these other guys aren't good but to me
it stands out a little that way
and then you know you get into trevor
lawrence and mac jones
you know the ball pops out of trevor
lawrence's hand too maybe not to the
same capacity
you know mack jones is not up to fields
or lawrence's capacity
but what lawrence and uh mack jones have
too a little bit
i i still with fields the natural
throwing motion
and at times i think the thing that i
didn't like about the workout was
it was a little bit you know relaxed and
i'm gonna take a drop and i'm just gonna
make sure i complete the throw
and do it that way where i feel like
zack wilson mac jones trevor lawrence
they drop back like it was a game and
like somebody's in front of me and i
gotta throw the ball
and there was that type of urgency where
i didn't feel like it was the same with
justin fields so again
i really like justin fields but i think
there's some things about his throwing
that are just not on par with the top
three or four guys in the draft uh as
compared to them
no doubt about justin field's running
ability there he is running the 40-yard
dash
4-4-3 i think is the number we saw chris
the caveat you've applied to all of the
40-yard dash times
it's not apples to apples in that it's
not happening in indianapolis laser
timing everyone there right
running under the similar conditions the
turf may be different the
the vibe may be different that's why
they love the scouting combine it gets
them all in one place but he's moving
fast as fast
regardless of whether it's four four
five four four eight four four two
four four whatever he's moving for a
quarterback four four
four is the number that it was so um
again we don't know what that would have
been at the scouting combine but there's
no doubting that justin fields
can move when he needs to and that's an
important trait for a guy to have when
he gets himself in trouble behind the
line of scrimmage whether it's buying
time horizontally
or taking off vertically if you've got
that speed
that's a difference man that it is i
mean that speed's real
no matter what and you know my general
rule is at a tenth right so if it's four
four four it's four five four at the nfl
combine
i think that's the rule that most teams
kind of apply to players
uh the film shows that type of speed you
know his running is special
and to me that's where you know he's a
tough prospect to evaluate a little bit
because you know yeah there's some
rawness in the drop back pass game and
decision making and some of the throws
but there is elite running ability
that can make up for the issues
that he might have in the past game to
help him
okay buy some time and come along with
that you know to where
you know i'm a guy that i sit there and
look at it and go
yeah i don't think he should be a
starter year one
you know i think in his best world he
could be that guy to like let's
let's learn behind somebody fix some of
the mechanical issues learn how to be a
pro maybe late in the season if the
team's bad
okay something like that but i do think
he'd be the guy that would benefit from
you know being behind someone but i
would think that there's teams out there
that go
well no wait you know we can orchestrate
an offense to where
you know he can run we can make defenses
defend
and have to worry about that quarterback
run game which can lead to really easy
pass looks
and now some of the things he's not as
good at
we don't have to worry about because
teams are worried about stopping the run
and now we make the pass looks really
easy for him
and i'm sure there's some teams that
look at it that way and think he can be
pro ready and ready to go for next
season
and since there can be no private
workouts this year because the pandemic
there will be
an ohio state slash justin fields pro
day
2 and kyle shanahan and john lynch will
be there for that one as they do their
due diligence
knowing lawrence and wilson will be gone
they're going to be picking
jones or fields or trey lance who goes
but they get they get their pick of the
guys left over after the first two are
off the board and they're happy about
that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports